driving to the front line through
territory that just three days ago was
held by warlord Khalifa half Dallas
forces this government soldier is
passing on intelligence about a possible
air attack he tells everyone to be
vigilant the threat from the air is
always present heavy artillery and air
power enabled half-dollars units to
overrun government forces and take the
town of a blue grain 80 kilometers east
of Misrata on Sunday but in the face of
a massive counter-offensive they could
only hold it for less than two hours
soldiers and civilians answered the call
the families of Misrata all together
United of one voice that when one hour
twenty thousand came from Misrata to a
per grain with ammunition and weapons
this is the new frontline after retaking
a blue grain units then pushed half task
forces back 20 kilometers they may be
wounded but they are not beaten they are
a well-equipped and heavily armed enemy
which can attack at any moment it's
dangerous they are using drones heavy
artillery rockets but God willing he
will protect us we are taking our
precautions they lost 11 men in the
weekend attack and a hundred were
injured including some civilians this is
the funeral the little girl who died of
natural causes but people have remained
here living with danger every day and
they are suffering we're facing live
shooting it's the biggest danger from
all sides its indiscriminate it's
difficult because in wars you can't
predict what will happen this medical
facility in nearby Zamzam is the only
community health care center for a
hundred kilometers the administrator
said after us fighters ransacked the
place and sold ambulances and all the
equipment it only adds to the misery and
increases the anger this young wounded
fighter has lost comrades his calling
after a dog he like many others may find
reconciliation difficult when peace
eventually
but many are growing weary of fighting
near work for local nah we prefer a
ceasefire we are all Libyans and we want
to stop the bloodshed but if these old
man after announces everyday that he
wants to take them all land and kill
more Libyan young man then we will
continue to fight until our last man
it's a wild rugged land where little
grows but so much blood is being spilled
to control it even though there is a
notional ceasefire in place no one yet
has declared the ceasefire dead but what
has happened here and in the sporadic
attacks in Tripoli showed just how
volatile the situation still is and how
quickly calm can turn to bloodshed
Tony Berkeley al-jazeera iboga rain east
of Misrata